Hello I’m Daven Hiskey, you’re watching
the Today I Found Out Youtube channel, in
the video today, we’re looking at why some
pages are intentionally left blank and why
they sometimes paradoxically print this on
the pages.
It's easy to dismiss the phrase, "This page
is intentionally left blank" and its usage
as an example of bureaucracy gone mad, but
it and the blank pages themselves are actually
there for good reason.
To begin with, the practise of marking intentionally
blank pages some form of "intentionally blank"
goes all the way back to the dawn of automated
printing itself, where mistakes in printing
were relatively common.
Like today, the main purpose of marking these
pages in this way was simply to make sure
people knew that the blank page wasn't a result
of a printing error.
Given this, it's no surprise that you'll almost
always only see this text on pages that you
might otherwise think shouldn't be blank given
their position in the written work.
This brings us around to the much more interesting
question of why any pages are left blank in
the first place.
After all, this is a waste of paper and potentially
a lot of money given the print volume of some
tests, pamphlets, books, etc.
As for the first on that list, in timed tests
an intentionally blank page is often used
as a shield of sorts to stop wily students
from trying to read the next section's questions
before they're supposed to.
To make sure no student is confused about
a random blank page in their test, they simply
indicate on the page some form of the somewhat
contradictory statement, "This page is intentionally
left blank".
Alternatively, they might put something like
"Stop Here" instead, so the student knows
to wait until the next timed section starts
and that the page is mostly blank for a reason.
Another reason to include a blank page, particularly
in certain official documents, is to avoid
ink from a pen potentially bleeding through
to another section of the document.
This is also one of the reasons you may sometimes
encounter otherwise blank pages saying something
like "Do not write anything on this page".
In both cases, the page is there simply to
prevent processing errors due to ink-bleed.
Blank pages in books and other bound works,
on the other hand, are generally there because
these works are often created by folding single,
large sheets of paper in very specific ways
and binding them all together.
This group of pages is known as a "signature"
and might include something like 4, 8, 16,
or 32 pages out of a single large sheet.
Regardless of how the paper is folded, the
end result is going to be a book or booklet
with an even number of pages.
If you look carefully at the spine of a book
you have lying around, you may even be able
to see this sort of grouping of pages if you
let it flair open a bit.
So, for example, if the content of the book
fills 299 pages, the layout artist might choose
a signature of 4- thus a minimum of 75 folded
sheets making up 300 total pages, including
one blank page.
On the somewhat extreme end, if the signature
comprises 32 pages (so 10 folded sheets making
up 320 pages), you'll have a whopping 21 blank
pages, making this signature likely a poor
choice here, though there still might be financial
or technical reasons to use it anyway.
Of course, savvy editors or layout artists
tend to try to tweak formatting to help the
book fit the chosen signature while minimizing
needed pages.
But inevitably there's going to be times where
nothing can be done and there will be a blank
page or pages.
In this case, they might resort to tricks
such as putting advertisements about some
of the other works by the author or publisher
in.
Alternatively, they might put in a short biography
on the author, rather than have it somewhere
on the cover.
Or, if necessary, they might move such a biography
to the cover to save a page within the book.
Alternatively, they might indicate the blank
page(s) are for the reader to take notes,
particularly in works like textbooks.
All of these tricks are basically ways of
avoiding a random blank page, or in some cases
needing to put something like "This page is
intentionally left blank" in the book.
Nevertheless, you'll still occasionally see
this text in some bound works, again in these
cases generally only put there in cases where
the editor in question thinks the reader might
think the page was not supposed to be blank.
So, for instance, you may have noticed that
many books have a blank page at the start
or end or both; this is a safe bet not to
confuse anyone, so is a handy way to mask
that the book's content didn't quite fit the
signature without needing to put "This page
intentionally left blank".
Bonus Fact:
• In the Principles of Federal Appropriations
Law (Second Edition, Volume IV) printed in
2001, the Office of the General Counsel in
the US General Accounting Office switched
things up a bit on the old "blank page that
isn't blank" conundrum.
Instead of stating "This page is intentionally
left blank", they wrote on one blank page
"This page is intended to be blank.
Please do not read it"...
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it please hit that thumbs up button
below and don’t forget to subscribe if you’re
not already.
And do check out our archives, we’re creeping
up on 700 videos now, so you’re sure to
find something you find interesting.
Thanks for watching.